I love to take on risk sometimes I eat  that challenge to get the best out of me  he hit shots and finds a way to get  himself out of jail okay but the gap I  had some of the shots that he's hit you  would say there's no chance he's gonna  get this up and down the epitome of Who  I am was the shot I hit on the 13th hole  out of the pine straw  Mickelson the greatest shot of his life  that defines my career the sense that  I'll do the exceptional and I pulled it  off for the victory the shot that he hit  TPC at Boston with one of the best I've  ever seen look at this he placed this  hard accelerating spinner no other  player that would ever try to play that  shot he hit this crazy high flop shot or  this crazy spin shot or used the slope  it's a weird way that no one else saw  [Applause]  it's felt that's really all you can say